to the ladies room I'm Kelsey and today
we have my mentor long-lost mom someone
I aspire to be very much like your
spirit animal my spirit animal Nicole
Polizzi here how are you thank you so
much for joining us and ladies hey
smokey were very excited when you doing
over there I didn't realize that I wore
this outfit twice in a row and I saw the
same guy you can change your underwear
I'm not wearing it so that's good yeah
easy accent I love your personality and
that you just like are who you are
because I feel like I'm the same way
you're the same person and recently I've
discovered that I'm like battling with
the word [ __ ] cause like something that
you don't like I hate that word you're
so gross we leave your meal because I
think having in front it's a very
powerful thing right like we've run the
world calling someone that is actually a
compliment how come we don't call people
ball sacks cuz ball sacks are really
sensitive and grows like vaginas can
take a beating I heard you're on
kocktails with khloé' recently yeah I
blacked out how was that so we got two
Khloe's and we were just in the waiting
room and I was like where's blicker
duh I was like why am I here we ended up
drinking a bottle champagne to ourselves
so right when I walked out I was already
like lit
and then she found me like three Jenks
and I don't remember the whole segment
of that show it's Chloe cool she's cool
yeah yeah yeah do you like me her better
you don't have dance that but yeah
you are the queen of DIY you love I try
you love like crafts and flipping and
yeah whooping and blipping is my
sarahfey you're really good at that
stuff so I have a scenario for you okay
I broke a strap on my dress this dress
is so gross I rather wipe my badge with
it I'm gonna give you this I can't sew
and then all of this stuff that's in my
purse it's all right something awesome I
love it
we're gonna have 30 seconds to do as
much fixing of the dress shop Oh
has this ever happened to you that you
ever like broke any feel or like a strap
or anything that continued being out I
broke a heel at my wedding
what and I just kept going girl
priorities guys wait you blood should
work how was it let's say you're not
gonna stay but it'll it'll do good until
you get home you guys that work hey
Brooklyn [ __ ] were means so now we're
gonna play jesus take the wheel did you
make this be more bubbly and turned and
made it oh is he gay yes
can you tell yes so we're gonna spin the
wheel and whatever it lands on we're
gonna do okay go for it
I do red cuz I'm classy and you do white
cuz you're home aren't you working you
get paid to get drunk I get paid to get
drunk me too it's the play used to her
cheers you are me like three years ago
oh god that's like the nice thing that's
like the most amazing compliment yeah
yeah um good question thank you with a
girl on Instagram it was like a group
picture and she brought me out of the
picture to put it on Instagram does that
mean she hates me I think it's because
you're hotter than her and she didn't
want people to see it
you were my favorite person before
you're like my favorite birthday so are
you gonna like unfollow around Instagram
or what do you do in that situation well
I'll probably keep following her can I
bring you tanning can you please I'm
from Florida they're chicken wings
they're literally chicken wings but
don't they kind of look good like
wouldn't you maybe if you're gonna fight
them if they were tanned would you yes
do you feel like when you're drunk
you're a little bit psychic I'm actually
trying over my third eye so I could be a
psychic
I believe in like ghosts and [ __ ] so I'm
trying to do that wait so you like wanna
see ghosts and stuff I already sense
them and I feel I feel them what are you
gonna do that when you meet a ghost is I
feel like once I see it goes I would
have no idea what the [ __ ] to do with
them I wanna say can you get Michael
Jackson I want to talk to him sometimes
I just I feel like I can predict the
future but alright predict my future
right now you're gonna have a UTI in the
next six weeks probably I used to get
them oh your time I'm really short
instead of going to the doctor's and
getting antibiotics I just drank tequila
to subside the pain and you're fine
you're like the friend I want to have I
don't have any friends can you do sorry
can't forgot you're a man we've come to
our last segment question what's your
signature drink um wine red
what's your hangover here fusses what's
the weirdest thing you've ever wiped
with a diaper excuse to leave a party
I'm horny favorite famous animal there
are famous cats uh what's the best
McClane you've ever given
sexpot goat you food when drunk pizza
what's your bedtime on a school night
7:00
and what's your bedtime on a weeknight
like or the weekend before or after bein
mom before 5:00 and after you did it do
you think we'll be friends if you buy me
drinks the way we end this is we can
consult be with our Polaroid okay don't
give it and then we hang it on the wall
of all the cool badass [ __ ] who have
come through the ladies so old-school
okay what phase are you making duck yeah
okay ready yes so what are you doing
later well yeah Kate can you narrate our
picture here we're giving it to you uh
don't be a ballsack drink in the middle
of the day thank you so much for coming
to the ladies room
this was the day I've ever had I like
you it's like meeting a person I only
ever saw on TV but know you're here yeah
this is great
you're very cool bye-bye